do you have a electric car yet like an
EV Tesla or anything I'm gonna come out
with my own car so how's your car really
come out with my own car How's that
gonna have uh like is this already is
this something that's real or are you
just saying it sometimes I feel like you
just be saying [__] I mean just it is it
this ain't this is this idea that I have
okay said that right now yeah okay but
you want to do a soldier hey come on man
you tell my electric car I was like come
on man but I like to touch a little got
the Bit TV screen do you have a Tesla
I got no Tesla man I like I gotta I like
like hellcats like I got the Hellcat
like I want to go fast I want to I want
to hear it you know but I like it though
it looked good right and you know stuff
like that it was just kind of slow but
did you see the Tesla's slow it's slow
which what
do you know that the test was the
fastest car that anybody can buy in the
United States then a Lamborghini yeah
it'll smoke the Tesla Model S plaid will
smoke though we're not talking about
Tesla Model flat we just want the
regular Tesla I'm telling you they're
smoking on Lamborghini man what okay
listen the Tesla Model S plaid yes
it's not Model S play at all Tesla
models can smoke a Lamborghini that's
what you tell I would say half of them
okay cool fix it half a model X and a
Model S well not all alone come on man
you're not telling me I might roll in
the wrong Tesla though you know what I'm
saying it was DJ Vlad Tesla I don't know
that [__] was slow it might have been
the right time wait first of all you're
hanging out with Vlad again it was a
long time ago it was a long time ago
that's what to say people would even
have me in the Tesla that [__] was slow
as [__] I was like what the [__] I gotta
go fast what was the car ride like with
you and DJ Vlad in the Tesla he's like
what soldier the car could drive itself
oh I'm like man watch out with this [__]
when are you gonna make your Triumph of
return to Vlad
I don't know for you know I'm gonna put
up on them I ain't sure are you guys
good now hell no
I'm full of them on them though we gonna
talk though you know I'm saying get a
little interview done I feel like it's
it's like
it also could be very
um
I feel like he'd probably throw you a
bag every three weeks to do an interview
like he does with boozy he I don't want
his money man yeah everything ain't
about the money sometimes just like
respect principles [__] like yeah like
morals you know what I'm saying you know
I got three Styles bro I can make money
yeah I can walk out of here and make
however much money I want right now you
know I appreciate that everybody
trying to bribe me to talk to you like
get the most out of here most artists
would not have your approach well that's
why I [__] with you bruh what's up what
would you do I did hear that you
recently okay because I don't think
people understand as an artist that you
do private gigs sometimes sometimes you
do stuff for like uh oh yeah like uh
maybe a bar mitzvah or you go and do
something for like a tech company yeah I
heard recently well maybe not too recent
that you had like a crazy show you did
in San Francisco was it for a tech
company or was it like a it was
something I'd be doing it was like a
private event but you got bagged out how
often are you getting like the private
event bags that we don't even hear about
that'd be coming a lot you know what I'm
saying I do a lot of regular shows I got
a tour coming up but then you're right I
do a lot of stuff that people can't even
get into and people don't even have you
ever done a bar mitzvah yeah what was
that like it was crazy it was like like
you said it was a bag they got money I'm
like y'all got money like that to be
paying for that like wow how many songs
did you have to do I was like two three
that's it yeah that's amazing yeah bar
mitzvahs I'm the best them the biggest
bags
I'm the biggest bags just go and do a
bar mitzvah clean up do two or three
songs eat the free food be on your way
okay a hundred percent but y'all get the
tickets I'm going on tour though Soldier
world uh in August I'm doing soldier
World in August 30 30 plus Days by 40
days okay um we're going everywhere who
you going out with just I mean have you
gotten this is my first headline until
you know saying my first two I did it
was me Chris Brown Bow Wow second tour
was this your first headlining tour of
your car myself or my whole career wow
because you go back and look at all my
tools you see me on tour with people you
see me with Wayne you see me with gz you
see me with bow wow everybody I'm saying
so now it's just me I'm gonna bring some
people out though like I'm gonna bring
some of my rap homies out I don't know
who but you know it's gonna be like
every city might be different it's gonna
be different every city that's crazy
crazy world I never I never if I could
have never have guessed that you never
did a headlining tour my whole career is
my first one another one I'm excited I'm
like I can't wait hop on that tour bus
hop on the plane you know I always
wonder like if you were to go to your
house in my head
like do you have like a museum and and
let's say the museum door opens up and
in the museum is like the first rubber
band necklace displayed the Gucci
headbands on display I got the Gucci
headband the sunglasses you know it's
crazy they just came
I don't want to say like I don't know
what channel I don't know what TV show
it probably has an area I'm probably
supposed to say but they're gonna put it
like in the one you know I'm saying Hall
of Fame joints I gave them the glasses
you gave him the glass I gave him the
glasses so they putting them in there
but did I keep the Gucci head mouth
there I kept the Gucci head man that
[__] so dirty it looks God by
the end of the last interview you did in
it it's Debbie it's dirty as [__] I got
it though isn't I got you can see it in
it I'm like nah let's just put that guy
down that was an error yeah it was I'm a
save I gotta say that that was a [__]
error the guy that she had been you can
never get rid of that you can't yeah no
that should go into like uh Smithsonian
some of the most memeable moments of all
time were with that headband on Drake
it's not for real